these buses in mandera County are
heading to Nairobi
first stop is at a police station where
they have to be escorted by armed police
through dangerous spots along the road
the Kenyan government has blamed
fighters from the armed group al-shabab
based in Somalia for launching attacks
here
they Ambush and plant improvised bombs
their targets are security forces and
civilians
says he's not traveling by Road anymore
it's far too dangerous and he cannot
afford an air ticket
you never know come out the figures and
life
it is our country
many other passengers here feel the same
way
the government is doing what it can we
cannot fault Security Forces but they
need to do more
Kenya shares a nearly 900 kilometer
border with Somalia the attacks started
shortly after it deployed troops to
Somalia to help defeat al-shabab
together with African Union forces this
is one of the most dangerous roads in
mandera a land mine exploded here not
too long ago and if you go further down
we're being told that seven people died
last year because of this incidence and
these are not isolated cases
this was the aftermath of that attack
that involved a minibus
mandera's Deputy Governor says the
fighters are moving further Inland a
kind of challenges are not worn only by
our security officers it is won by the
community by the people who live there
and we are engaging heavily with the
community in terms of awareness in terms
of providing the necessary information
to our security agencies
passengers start their perilous Journey
it's going to take them 24 hours to get
to the capital city they say they just
want to get through the risky stretch so
they can breathe again
Catherine soy Al Jazeera mandera
Northeastern Kenya